what ups face fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the arguably controversial
philosophy of the even plan I asked you
guys recently one of my chapter reviews
if you'd like to see a video like this
and a lot of you said you would so here
it is if you like seeing demons their
content on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell or else you
won't know when future demons air videos
come out for more philosophy and
self-development content make sure to
fall project uproar on Instagram and
YouTube link in the description I
regularly share practical philosophical
insights there so check it out if that
sounds like something you'd enjoy also
there will be manga spoilers in this
video I enjoy actually getting deep into
the content and you can't do that while
avoiding spoilers so if spoilers bother
you you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into the
philosophy of demon slayer i immediately
noticed the difference between demons
and a lot of other Shonen manga and
anime if you didn't know Shonen is the
most popular demographic in japan for
manga according to the ever trustworthy
wikipedia Shonen are primarily targeted
towards boys between the ages of 12 and
18 that doesn't mean the six-year-old
woman can't enjoy them they're just not
the main intended demographic demon
slayer is a shounen manga like one piece
Naruto black clover and my hero academia
but there's an interesting difference we
will first look at some of these other
Shonen manga so that we can better
understand demon slayer by contrast so
bear with me
usually Inchon and manga the main
character wants to be the best or
strongest in some way and the series is
about them pursuing that goal for
instance luffy wants to be the pirate
king naruto wants to be Hokage auste
wants to be the wizard King and dekha
wants to be the greatest hero in these
anime the fact that these characters
have this huge ambition and won't
compromise him if it means fighting
destiny itself is presented as a good
thing there's more nuance to it but the
general idea is that through willpower
and hard work they'll be able to
overcome any obstacle they just need to
have the belief in themselves and try
hard enough these characters often go
around loudly proclaiming to people that
they will be the best they will achieve
their goal no matter what for instance
even when Austin lost his ability to use
his arm
was told that he'd never be able to
swing a sword again he refuses to give
up on his dream he calls out fate itself
he is willing to fight against destiny
luckily his arms got healed but what if
he was injured as bad as Rocklea after
the gara fight Rockne wasn't talented
but he works harder than arguably anyone
in order to become a great ninja then he
gets defeated by a pallet that someone
who worked less hard than him he got
severely injured in the battle if he
wants to keep being a ninja he needs to
undergo surgery there's a 50% chance
that he'll die from that surgery as
Rocklea says and I quote this time
working hard or believing myself won't
change a thing and quote again luckily a
surgery successful and Rocklea can keep
being a ninja however what if he was
injured so bad that surgery wouldn't
help and he couldn't be a ninja
what if also was injured so bad that he
couldn't be the wizard King what if they
tried everything and they reached a
point where hard work really wouldn't
change a thing all of a sudden their
philosophy has become a very dangerous
thing if Austin can only be happy by
being the wizard King and Rock Lee can
only be happy by being a strong ninja
then if they are irreversibly injured
they have been sentenced to a life of
misery shown in perhaps because it is
geared towards younger demographics
often avoid such inconvenient and
depressing outcomes they like to imply
that you can overcome destiny itself
with enough hard work and fighting
spirit but that's not necessarily the
case in real life now just to clarify
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with having big ambitions there's
nothing wrong with also I have to be the
wizard King however let's explain the
right way to go about this according to
stoic philosophy which will give us a
useful lens to use in this video and
stoic philosophy is strikingly similar
to Buddhist philosophy which has
influenced even ser as we'll see later
I'll use stoic philosophy specifically
because I'm more familiar with it but it
should be said that a lot of what I'm
about to mention goals for Buddhist
philosophy to a stoic would tell Austen
not to fight against destiny but to go
with it after all if it truly is destiny
by definition it can't be changed
the Stoics would advise us to accept
things that we cannot change
so if Austen could not fight any more
despite trying everything he possibly
could he should accept that as humans we
have the ability to decide what we focus
we can focus on what we can't have and
live a miserable life or we can be
grateful for what we do have and live a
happy life if Austin could no longer
fight he could still be grateful for
being alive he couldn't look for other
ways to help his kingdom and his friends
the point is he could be happy even if
he wasn't able to fight and become the
wizard King you should frame your goals
no matter how ambitious in such a way
where you can't fail let me explain for
instance entrepreneur gary vaynerchuk's
goal is to try to buy the New York Jets
he enjoys the journey of trying to get
to this goal he'll do everything he
possibly can to get to that goal but in
the end he won't be miserable for the
rest of his life if he fails to buy the
Jets
similarly the Stoics would be fine with
Austin's external goal of being the
wizard king however Oscar should reframe
his goal as follows I will do everything
within my power to increase my
likelihood of becoming the wizard King
the idea is to do your best you
literally can't do more than that enjoy
the process of doing your best and in
the end if you don't succeed that's
alright you committed to the process of
doing your best but all the while you
were detached from the outcome after all
if you were costly obsessing over the
outcome you would arguably be less clear
minded and effective in your execution
of the process now let's finally look at
Demon Slayer we now know how the idea of
fighting destiny and believing that you
can accomplish anything if you just work
hard enough is not stoic you can make
your destination as ambitious as you
want but higher happiness is the process
of doing your best rather than on
attaining that goal the stoic idea is
that we can be happy under almost any
circumstances if we frame them the right
way however if we frame them the wrong
way we can turn even a heavenly
situation into hell in our own minds
suffering mainly comes from us desiring
our reality to be different than it is
however the Stoics would say that we
don't have to be slaves to our desires
we can at any point choose to desire the
things we have rather than desiring
things we don't have or can't ever have
in demon slayer the mangaka shows us how
the usual Shona philosophy can go
terribly wrong through the character of
Upper Moon one Coco Cibo coco she will
perhaps mistook himself for short
protagonists but alas he was a side
character in a
what unconventional Shonen manga ever
since he was a kid Coco Chabot who
wasn't called Coco Chabot then but Michi
katsu sugi Cooney wanted to be the
number one samurai his brother Yuri she
didn't need to be number one he would
have been fine if Coco Shiba was
stronger than him he even said as a kid
that he wanted to become the second
strongest samurai so that his brother
could be the first right off the bat
Kakashi bo has more in common with
Michonne and protagonist than your Ichi
Kakashi bow is the one that's striving
for the number one position he is
willing to work as hard as it takes to
get there he wants to be the best no
matter what in contrast yuuichi is not
like the conventional Shana protagonist
everything he does seems so effortless
he doesn't have that need to be number
one he can be happy even if you were
never to accomplish such an ambitious
goal so if we use usual shown and logic
who should become the strongest samurai
well kakushi bow obviously he wants to
be the best he stated his goal and he's
prepared to work hard as hard as it
takes to achieve his goal however the
usual laws of Shonen are reversed your
Ichi the one who isn't obsessed with
being number one ends up being number
one the one who doesn't care about the
outcome is the one who ends up being the
strongest you reach you add weight less
practice than cocoa Chivo beats a sword
expert badly in a sparring match the
first time he tries he doesn't get
excited about his power and how it
increases the chance that he'll be too
strong at samurai rather he says he no
longer wants to be a samurai because he
can't stand how it feels hitting people
eventually though despite how reluctant
he is he lifts his sword for the greater
good
he uses his sword to kill demons and
save people cuckoo she both thought that
he put in every ounce of effort he
couldn't grow stronger than his brother
but it never worked
while cocoa Shiva was obsessed with
swordsmanship the extremely talented yo
Deecee was bored of such conversations
eventually at Ichi left but came back
later to save kakushi bow when he was
attacked by a demon
cuckoo she bolted peacefully for the ten
years that your Ichi was gone but when
he returned he couldn't help but compare
himself to his little twin brother again
he was shocked at how you teach he had
mastered the sword it destroyed his
serenity and his stomach began to burn
with envy
and hate believing that he could remedy
this situation with more hard work
Koko's evil committed to training and
becoming a Demon Slayer as he said no
matter the cost I wanted to make his
strength and sword skills my own in
order to do this Kagoshima abandoned his
home wife and children but no matter how
hard he worked he still couldn't catch
up to your Ichi
to make matters worse he manifested a
mark which meant he was going to die
soon then moves on came he offered to
turn him into a demon this would give
him more power and make him immortal
kikuchiyo willing to sacrifice
everything for his dream of being number
one agreed to become a demon and
abandoned his humanity and still when he
came across an over 80 year old Europe
sheet he still was nowhere close to his
level
yuuichi cut him before he could even
react and then you reach he died of old
age standing up meaning that Koko Shiba
would never be able to beat him no
matter how much effort he put into
training no matter what he sacrificed it
wasn't enough the need to be number one
wasn't presented as a positive thing
that drives people to be the best
versions of themselves rather the
desperate need to be number one made
kokeshi Bo's life miserable and
literally turned him into a monster
in contrast the guy who didn't care
about being number one and even smiled
at the thought that someone would
surpass him in the future
ended up being number one rather than
costly saying that he'd be the best he
was humble he said that he wasn't so
great for your each sheet he viewed
himself as just a line in the long long
book of human history this guy who did
his best but never felt the need to be
the best is the one that became the
strongest samurai to me this story is
fascinating it shows the dark side of
being desperately attached to an outcome
that ultimately you don't have control
over
Rock Lee was willing to risk death
rather than living the rest of his life
not being able to fight as a ninja
luckily there was a chance to bring his
ability to fight back
but if there wasn't there were other
options available aside from him just
killing himself he could have found
happiness and meaning in contributing to
the village in any other way that he
could perhaps he would have become a
famous shinobi philosopher
similarly Kakashi Bo didn't have to be
miserable if he really wanted to try to
be the best samurai then he showed me
his gold
Holloway I will do my best as I ain't
Ord becoming the number one samurai
while not violating my own principles as
long as he was doing his best he should
have been happy and enjoyed the journey
even if he never became the best
alternatively he could have looked at
all the other stuff he had going in his
life that you reach he didn't he picked
one thing that your ichi was naturally
better at and decided that he couldn't
be happy until he surpassed it however
he could have instead been thankful for
what he had for instance he had a
beautiful family and he had a life where
he didn't have to kill demons all the
time
he could have devoted his time to
philosophy or literature he could have
contribute to society in a different way
the Stoics would have been very critical
of Koko she Bo's behavior not only was
he willing to discard all of his
principles he also tied his happiness to
something he couldn't control the fact
is that we can always choose to be happy
right now with where we're at while
improving their situation day by day we
can focus on the reasons we have to be
grateful rather than on the reasons we
have to be miserable if you're watching
this right now it means that you're
breathing imagine how many dead people
wish they were in your shoes right now
or imagine how many potential people
were never even born and will never get
to experience the ultimate gift of life
does it make sense to squander this
short life by getting upset that someone
is a better swordsman than you remember
only one person can be the best at
something but that doesn't mean the
other billions of people have to be
miserable or even that that one person
will be happy at the top in fact a lot
of people feel empty when they achieve
their goal because they're looking in
the wrong place for fulfillment
fulfillment can't come from the outside
it has to come from within if you can't
be happy right now chances are you won't
be happy even when you accomplish your
goals
just to clarify again I don't think that
setting exterior goals like trying to be
the best samurai is bad but make sure
you are enjoying the journey and that
you can be happy giving you your best
even if you never become the best I
think there's also a reason that ton
zeros goal is not simply to be the
strongest samurai rather it is to do
everything he can to save his sister
while living up to his principles of
being a good moral person panchito's
raison d'être or reason for living is to
do the right
and tried to help others first and
foremost rather than being the best
there's even an interesting point where
net Sukho is about to be burned by the
Sun but Tanja recovers her the enemy
demon is about to escape and as go
kickstand Jiro in that direction
seemingly sacrificing herself so that he
could kill that demon now one of
country's main goals was saving mezack o
from the beginning but he accepts her
decision and goes after the demon even
if it means that go dying luckily nesco
doesn't die and becomes the only demon
that can withstand the sun but the point
is that even when ton zero supposed main
goal was threatened he didn't become
miserable and fall apart even if
netskope didn't make it he would have
went on doing the right thing he would
have done his duty and continued to save
people from demons that is the same way
a stoic would respond he wouldn't fall
apart because of something he can't
control he would focus on what he could
control and help in any way he could
another interesting thing is tons o
selfless or non self state in this state
hunter is the strongest version of
himself he can even temporarily
overpower Icaza and guess what's the
main characteristic of this overpowered
state it has no fighting spirit or
killing intent fighting spirit is
usually portrayed as a good thing the
more fighting spirit the more determined
you are to win the better your chances
right well not necessarily in this state
Thunder let's go of the desired outcome
he lets go of the desire to kill Icaza
and he is actually stronger as a result
how does this make sense well the great
archery master Hawk Enzo might be able
to help explain the power of detachment
for him obsessing over the outcome was
the enemy of mastering any art he
suggested his archery students put the
idea of hitting the target out of their
minds
he said and I quote the hits on the
target are only the outward proof and
confirmation of your purposelessness at
its highest of your egolessness your
self-abandonment or whatever you like to
call this state and quote the idea here
is that the more we desperately want
something or need it to happen the more
difficult it actually is to achieve in
the bhagavad-gita it is written that
work done for a reward is much lower
than work done in the yoga of wisdom
said thy heart upon thy work
never on its reward work not for the
reward but never cease to do thy work
and quote this quote should address the
concern that if you detach from the
outcome you won't feel motivated anymore
the idea is that you should do your work
like tangelo you should do the right
thing every day but you'll be even more
successful if you let go of the
desperate need to be successful when
Pancho clears his mind and just focus on
doing the dance of the fire-god properly
he is actually able to surpass Icaza but
he wasn't able to do this while he was
worrying about needing to kill a casa in
order to save gives life the key is to
focus on the process while letting go of
the outcome
thus in Austin's case he should
according to this philosophy enjoy the
process of doing his best rather than
obsessing over whether or not he will
actually become the wizard king so that
is the difference I've noticed between
demons there and a lot of others shown
and that seemed to glorify the idea that
you can be the best at anything if you
work hard enough I agree that hard work
will always increase your likelihood of
success but obsessing over the outcome
rather than focusing on the process will
hurt rather than help you according to
the philosophies we've discussed in this
video and personally I found that I'm
able to perform better and enjoy the
process more when I let go of the
outcome well let me know what you think
in the comments I'd love to hear from
you if you did enjoy this video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell or you
won't get notified when new Demon Slayer
videos come out for more philosophy and
sauce about my concepts follow my
instagram at project uproar and the
project uproar youtube channel i'll link
both in the description a big thank you
goes out to our patrons over on patreon
who helped make videos like this one
possible i especially want to thank our
pro here to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings ljus angel Cruz Steelers
poet Pablo atropos Wraith $30 beat Akagi
and Anatoly Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Stephen and Radha al-hola Optim Matty
back to 39 makoto-kun and your boy said
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon
common app for and becoming a patron
today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin if
you're interested you can also now join
the YouTube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer no matter
what way you choose to support us you'll
get the same great benefits anyways
thanks again for everything and until
next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]